hey I'm back in this video we're going
to talk about the heart in relationship
to nutritional deficiencies one of the
problems that you're running into is
when you go to the doctor there's just
not enough attention or importance put
on food in the relationship to how it
affects the body especially the heart or
diet they just don't put attention on
that it's not emphasized enough but the
heart is one of the main muscles of the
body that responds to nutrition more
than anything else very quickly okay and
you can do research on each thing I'm
talking about and find a lot of great
data but mainly just want to kind of
cover some key points here number one
arrhythmias that happens when you have a
problem with the pacemaker of the heart
there's a part of the heart it's a
neurological thing that keeps the heart
and rhythm and it requires electrolytes
when there's not enough electrolytes you
can have problems with the pacemaker and
have all sorts of issues with extra
beats missing beats of beat that's not
an rhythm anymore all sorts of abnormal
heart rhythm problems happen in your
body like atrial fibrillation for
example let's first start with calcium
calcium normally helps you contract
muscles okay it's involved in a lot of
things but that would be one thing that
it does let's say for example you have
too much calcium or not enough calcium
you can have a lot of issues so calcium
deficiency can cause tetany that little
twitch that happens like maybe right
below your left eye like or in your arm
that's a calcium deficiency or if you
have too much calcium that can also
create a rhythm problem with the heart
as well so if you're missing magnesium
for example you could have a leg cramp
because magnesium is involved in
relaxation of muscle so you have this
contraction of the muscle controlled by
the calcium and the relaxation of the
muscle controlled by magnesium they both
work together now if you have this thing
in the heart where you have looked up
lub-dub you have this contraction and
relaxation contraction relaxation and
you have the systolic diastolic type
pressure too so if you have an imbalance
in the systolic and the diastolic it
could be a problem with
minerals or it could be a problem with
vitamin b1 because the autonomic nervous
system is that system that regulates the
heartbeat unconsciously so it just runs
the heartbeat on a certain pattern so it
could be a b1 deficiency it could be a
problem with calcium
another problem with calcium in general
is that if you don't have enough vitamin
d3 you don't get the absorption of
calcium too much because vitamin d3
increases the absorption of calcium by
20 times in the small intestine okay now
vitamin k2 is very very important to it
in making sure you don't build up too
much calcium in the arteries or the
other soft tissues like the joints so
you need these both together I recommend
a ratio of 10,000 IU's of d3 to 100
micrograms of k2 okay
I like the mk7 version that's the
natural version so like if you have a
big problem with calcium buts clogging
up the arteries and things I would
recommend taking these ratios like maybe
times for X in a given day if you have a
mild problem or you want to maintain it
you can just take a like a 10,000 IU's -
100 microgram ratio now it's part of the
pH goes if your pH is too alkaline
you can't transport calcium too well the
calcium doesn't really move that well so
you need a an acidic pH to transport
calcium so again even the pH can alter
the transportation of minerals the acid
level in your stomach controls the
absorption of minerals too so that could
be another problem there's another
condition where you have nano bacteria
nano bacteria is a very small little
microbe that lives in a little calcium
shell and it can hide out in your heart
and your kidney in your mouth and if you
look up nano bacteria and plaque in the
arteries you'll find a whole bunch of
data okay they're finding now with these
new microscopes that there's microbes in
the calcium and the the probably reason
why the calcium is there is one of the
reasons is the microbe
is attracting the calcium to protect it
so it can hide as a stealth mechanism so
you can't find it so in that case you'd
want something to dissolve that calcium
plaquing like a good key later EDTA is a
really good one I highly recommend it
because that's a powerful calcium key
later it also pulls out heavy metals
it's great for cardiovascular issues
also if you had a stroke and you want to
get the arteries cleaned up it's a
really great product well research you
can look it up it's called EDTA but if
you dissolve the calcium shell and you
want to kill the nano bacteria you want
to use things like a regular oil clove
things like that that actually are like
a natural herbal antibiotic without the
side effects now if you're low on sodium
you can feel very very weak okay and if
you have too much sodium your blood
pressure goes up let's say you have a
lot of refined foods and no vegetables
you can have a lot of sodium very low
potassium and you're going to be
waterlogged you're gonna have swelling
and edema all over the place
so we need some salt but we don't need
like way more than the other mineral
called potassium so we need to balance
there but here's the thing if you're in
a low salt diet or if you're trying to
so-called lower your blood pressure and
you cut out the salt okay and you're
drinking a lot of water
now we dilute that electrolyte and it's
called hyponatremia and now we actually
get all sorts of other health problems
because we're becoming more dehydrated
by drinking water because we don't have
the electrolytes as a solution what
hydrates you is not water it's fluids
you need a combination of water and
electrolytes at the same time because
when you drink pure water or even
distilled water or whatever and you're
peeing out urine the urine has a lot of
electrolytes but the water has very few
so you create this imbalance if you
drink too much water and you don't have
enough sodium just a point to research
magnesium is very very important in
muscle preventing muscle cramps it's
also important in helping you relax it's
important in key enzymes to help in
price 600 different chemical reactions
in the body you get a lot of magnesium
in chlorophyll which happens to be the
green in the plants the vegetables
you're consuming which I'm assuming that
you're consuming at least seven cups a
day you're gonna get enough magnesium
from that but also you need the
potassium which also comes from the same
source a vegetable so if you consume
enough vegetables like 7 to 10 cups
you'll get you'll kill both of these
birds with one stone you need a lot more
potassium than magnesium though but the
problem is you're going to be worried
about getting enough of it because you
need 40 700 milligrams that's a lot you
need it for the electrical conductivity
of the the nervous system and the muscle
so if you're deficient in this you can
definitely have rhythm problems in the
heart atrial fibrillation and all sorts
of things but most of the potassium is
stored inside the cell not outside the
cell so when you get your blood tested
it's just normal that doesn't mean
anything because they're not actually
testing interest cellular potassium
that's a special test the point I'm
making is just to bring your awareness
up of all the different factors so
you're not like worried about it but
you're just eating healthy and and now
you know why you should eat healthy
because of these reasons you're
preventing a lot of issues not
necessarily to test every little thing
but just to know the connection your
pulse rate can go high if your potassium
goes down potassium actually helps lower
blood pressure and lower the pulse rate
so when you don't have enough potassium
it can go up okay you can have high
blood pressure if you're low on
magnesium to insulin resistance as a
condition where the cell can't really
absorb the minerals too well anymore and
you start developing all sorts of issues
within the arteries like damaged artery
walls and then comes the calcium you
your order gets stiff so you can start
developing conditions Harding of the
arteries arterial sclerosis things like
that and what you have to do is you have
to get to the source cut down the carbs
don't eat so frequently I have the
videos down below if this is your first
video but it's probably not so you
probably know all about it but if you
don't there's a link down below insulin
resistance is like a real big problem
people take diuretics for high blood
pressure but what happens is that they
it pulls out sodium and potassium well
we need to keep the potassium one thing
you might want to do is it really
increase your potassium as a primary way
of helping you lower this we
a lot of vegetables it may just work
okay angina this is a situation when you
get the heart that cramps okay you have
a heart attack the heart cramps
one key vitamin could be responsible and
that's vitamin E vitamin E is very very
important in keeping the heart from
cramping keeping the oxygen up in the
muscle so if you're deficient in vitamin
E the amount of oxygen goes way down in
the muscle so it's very susceptible to
getting cramps and so you want to make
sure you take a whole food vitamin
complex or just consume foods that are
high in vitamin E like seeds and nuts
and vegetables things like that this is
a fat soluble vitamin now so that could
be one trigger plaquing usually develops
after a lesion or an oxidative problem
with the artery wall because the person
is consuming too much sugar okay or they
get exposed to iron which is like rust
and then what happens because sugar or
glucose is very similar in the chemistry
to vitamin C by the way they're very
similar if there's glucose in the system
it will absorb that and not vitamin C
and therefore you're going to create a
deficiency of vitamin C so if given the
choice the body will take priority from
glucose so now if you don't have enough
vitamin C the antioxidant the protective
factor you get oxidation damage to the
artery wall and then comes the calcium
and then comes the cholesterol as a
band-aid to plaque it and you start
getting a clogged artery heart attacks
for example a lot of times it can occur
during stress events because the adrenal
triggers them the adrenal hormone called
adrenaline which is produced by the
inside of the adrenal has one function
of vaso dilating the coronary artery
that's the main blood supply to the
heart itself okay so if that artery
doesn't they so dilate to get more blood
flow let's say you're under stress it's
supposed to open up to handle the new
blood flow that is happening when you're
being chased by a tiger so you can get
out there so you have more blood flow to
the heart that are
doesn't open up and it constricts
because your adrenals are burnt out boom
another heart attack especially if
there's plaquing in there so there's
there's a lot of crossover here vitamin
b1 is really important in preventing the
heart from enlarging there's something
called cardiomegaly where the heart
enlarges if it doesn't have enough b1
also the pulse rate will go up if you
don't have b1 a lot of respiratory
problems and breathing problems or you
don't have b1 as well but in b2 and b3
and even b6 are also involved in helping
the artery vasodilate as well so some of
the B vitamins help the arteries
constrict and some vasodilate but if
you're deficient of these two you may
have more vasoconstriction contributing
to this heart attack right here and by
the way vitamin b3 which is nice and
helps to keep cholesterol in check as
well but if you're doing a lot of sugar
in these sugars being converted to
cholesterol
okay vitamin b3 won't even touch it okay
it won't even affect it so you really
need to clean up the sugar to handle
your cholesterol fully alright so I hope
I increased your awareness on the
relationship between nutrients and heart
health thanks for watching so I want to
know about what you think about this
video so please comment below and tell
me what you think